[Music]
hi I'm meadow Carm The Economist's
deputy editor and I'm a lock jaw the
economists science correspondent we've
received many many questions from you
and we're going to try and answer some
of them right now
[Music]
overall impact on the economy over the
next few months partly depends upon what
governments do there's a trade-off if
you like the more governments try and
keep people at home in order to stop the
disease spreading the bigger the effect
on the economy but already you've had
various people who are following this
like the vet the lobby group for hotels
and and and hospitality in the u.s.
saying that they think the effect of
this will be as big as 9/11 and the
global financial crisis wrapped up in
one you've seen Airlines calling for
many many billion dollars in age you
seen an uptick in unemployment already
and Steve Newton the Treasury secretary
warning that without action unemployment
could reach 20 percent and in the real
place we've actually seen this effect
more than anywhere else so far which is
China
you saw the various numbers for
industrial production retail sales
falling thirteen twenty percent many
times more than people were expecting
the model people have used initially
when they started with SARS which was a
similar kind of disease stuck in struck
in 2003 in the bounce-back there was
really quick but I think one of the
reasons we've seen extreme Falls in
stock markets and other asset markets is
it's become increasingly clear that SARS
isn't a very good model the problems go
deeper and they'll last longer now one
of the things that government policy is
trying to do is to keep essentially
solid businesses that just happen to be
hit by everyone staying at home to keep
those businesses going so that when
things start to improve they can pick up
reasonably quickly the worry is that a
lot of businesses go bankrupt and then
the process the scarring if you like in
the economy you're much worse than the
process of recovery or be that much
worse so people have like three shapes
of recession in mind one is the V shape
from SARS I think that's looking very
unlikely one is the the other is the U
shape where the bottom is quite long but
things really do pick up and kind of go
back to where they were and the one we
want to avoid by saving companies and
saving jobs is an l-shape recession
where things go down and they stay down
so it's particularly hard for people who
live hand-to-mouth you know if you don't
have savings and you have to go you have
to get the crowded bus to work every day
your chances of catching the disease are
higher your resources if you do catch
the disease and you can't work are
smaller your ability to go and see a
doctor who's got the solar healthcare
that can help you infinitesimally
I think you know it's going to be really
really tough for such people there are a
couple of things that might help often
many of these many people in these
countries tend to be of a younger
demographic group and we know that the
disease is particularly harsh on
people the rural populations in some of
these countries are larger and it's
easier you know to keep away from people
if you're in the countryside but they
also have very big favelas and very big
slum districts which are crowded so I
think it's going to be particularly
tougher and it's often the way isn't it
that you know disease is the hips the
what whole world hit poor people worst I
just say one other thing to add which is
when you take say the Ebola virus in
2014 you've got quite a good response
from outside West Africa to help and
that was um partly to do with
humanitarian instincts but partly
self-interest the rich world didn't want
to see a Boehner go well right now there
isn't you know the world's preoccupied
with its own problems
I think it's wishful thinking just
because there's not much good evidence
to suggest that hot temperatures would
slow down the spread of this infection
there's no mechanism for that
necessarily um however what we should
expect to see in many countries is that
as the summer months come the cases will
probably dip and that's not because of
the effects on the virus itself but
because more people are going to be
outside in the open air and less likely
to be inside rooms with people who are
infected and so that's something you see
in seasonal flu and all sorts of things
that does mean though that when winter
comes you're gonna see another rise and
so yes heat in an indirect way Lutece
infections but I do think there's
anything it would suggest that the
actual virus itself is going to stop
that way it's a fact that it will mutate
every virus will mutate because it's
there's an evolutionary arms race it
wants to infect you and multiply and go
out into the world has infecting the
people if your body or your oh there's a
vaccine that sort of stops it and that's
something you'll find a way around it
and there was some early evidence maybe
a month or so ago that the this
particular strain of the corona virus
had mutated to some extent and so we
were dealing with too and we're not sure
what's happening with that exactly yet
most mutations are don't make any
difference really to the infection rates
and so on and you know the one array of
good news about that mutations is that
generally speaking a pathogen wants to
if it's new in humans it wants to be
able to survive in humans for as long as
possible and so what it does is it tries
to sort of become less virulent and
because it doesn't kill you as much as
quickly because it wants to spend the
time reproducing so actually most
infections most mutations you see tend
to be on that type and yes there's
always the possibility that you take to
something else completely and seasonal
flu does that seasonal flu is different
every year and we have to come up with a
new vaccine every year for it but but in
general in general and they will eat
will mutate and we just have to keep a
watch on it there are some other corona
viruses out there
a couple of which cause colds and those
those also are things that reinfect us
every year so it's too early to say
whether this this corona virus will be
similar but but you know it's something
to bear in mind that this could become a
seasonal kind of infection and that you
know you need to have vaccines if they
find a vaccine eventually you have
vaccines that are kind of predicting how
what kind of seasonal version you'll
have that's the billion dollar question
and it takes normally a vaccine it takes
something like five or ten or twenty
years to introduce one from scratch
we've never seen this this particular
corona virus before and so there are
some ideas of what might you might you
might do just sort of try and tackle it
but where we starting from scratch
pretty much now we're hoping that's not
going to take 20 years to create a
vaccine they were in the wake of the
Ebola epidemic five or six years ago new
practices were put into place to try and
speed up the introduction of new
vaccines to try and do the trials faster
because you've got to go through many
stages of clinical trials which involves
safety for human volunteers and then
giving them to people who actually have
the infection and so new protocols are
put into place that allow you to develop
a vaccine in quick time during the
course of an epidemic now even then it
will take something like 18 months to a
couple of years before you're seeing
vaccines available people
[Music]
unfortunately all my alters are we need
hot data but I do know that there's a
study about to start exactly that so
we'll find out in about two years and
then they'll be long-term studies as
well this will be one of those things
that people write about in economics
textbooks in the future of the of the
generation that left school for six
months and what happened to them yeah I
imagine they're more creative more
inquisitive obviously in the very short
run there are you know emissions have
gone down and and and you know I've
heard claims or I haven't seen the
evidence of it that you know there are
fewer people dying in China at the
moment because there aren't so many road
traffic accidents and because the skies
are clear there aren't so many people
ingesting sort of toxins through aerial
pollution but but and you know most of
the things that people are thinking
about here are stocks you know there are
stocks of carbon dioxide ants and stocks
of greenhouse gases and this makes very
little difference to the stocks and in
addition to that you know if you get a
big slowdown in investment it slows the
transition out of electric vehicles
photovoltaic cells wind power and so
forth so I'm not at all convinced that
it's a net positive for nature
[Music]
[Applause]
let me give you my hopes rather than
what I think it will look like look like
one thing that I hope is that we as a
society take more value in our experts
there's been through various populist
tough uprisings in the last few years
that you know you know I still really
move towards not believing people who
seems to be an authority and you know
although some of that might just be a
hype I feel like there is this thing of
like you know scientists and people who
study all these sort of arcane ideas
about how how the world works and might
not be so useful to everyday existence
well this shows you that a lot of that
stuff is incredibly important in our
responses to how the world operates
so this pandemic was predicted multiple
times by many many people and you can
argue that some people listen to some
people didn't for those same sorts of
people scientists are telling us about
climate change
I'm not a longer-term thing and we don't
seem to be doing much on that front or
haven't been doing anyway
so I hope that there's a greater respect
for these sorts of models and
predictions that people are making I
also hope that I also hope that it sort
of does allow us to just appreciate that
you know globalization is this wonderful
force that's created and much more
opportunity for the world and and and
wealth and so on but that we don't we we
aren't all the separate countries that
exist don't there isn't there's no
boundaries for viruses there's no fun of
boundaries of pathogens and diseases and
then actually coordination is incredibly
important for all of these things we've
been seeing the world separating itself
politically in many ways and I hope that
this reverses some of that we're
dedicated to bring you the best
reporting we can with the best analysis
of this phenomenal story as it changes
from one day to the next and if you want
to keep up with what we're doing all of
our coverage is available if you just
click on the link you can see and thanks
for watching